[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive here at toys at Sky News
time to see what's making the headlines
with our fantastic guests as well
tonight Allison Morris columnists with
the Belfast Telegraph joins as well so
does the former conservative special
advisor Anita patang very good to have
you both on the program thank you so
much for joining us tonight they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight this evening let's have a look
what's on some of those front pages for
you now starting with the mail it leads
on mortgages with the headline mortgage
crisis hunt easing the pain in reference
to Jeremy Hunt striking a deal with
banks to help families hit by surging
mortgage repayments Jeremy Hunt's
mortgage pact also takes the lead for
the Ft tomorrow their headline reads
Banks to delay repossessions for 12
months onto the telegraph it also has
that story on their front cover quoting
Grant shapes with the headline
households spared 120 pound Net Zero
Levy
the times tomorrow leads with the claim
that millions of public sector workers
face having a pay rise is a six percent
blocked by the government amid mounting
concerns that they would fuel inflation
while the mirror reports on the doctor's
five-day strike saying Medics ramp up
action with the longest walkout in NHS
history UK hit by exempic shortages for
weight loss drug is the lead for the I
newspaper which reports on an
unprecedented demand in the popular
injection has led to supply issues on to
the guardian for you reporting on a
tsunami of dangerous Vapes flooding into
the UK
caring Prince's mission to honor Diana's
memory is the headline on the express
tomorrow morning reporting on Prince
William's Steely determination it says
to tackle homelessness in honor of his
late mother
invasion of the killer Hornets is the
daily Stars report on a horde of hornets
that could kill people with their stings
which are set apparently to invade
Britain
well a reminder that by scanning the QR
code that you see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch with us and of course we hope that
you do and of course I said earlier
we're tonight joined by Alison Morris
and Anita botany let's go and chat to
them now and start with some really
interesting front pages to get through
uh ladies very good evening to you and
welcome startless up the Daily Mail and
it's front page mortgage crisis hunt
eases the pain of course uh well
documented in a meeting today with
Jeremy Hunt and some of the Britain's
biggest banks CEOs all are in number 11.
um what what do you make of the coverage
let's start with you Alice and how what
do you make of how the Daily Mail have
set it out
yeah well I mean it is interesting
because we had heard that there may have
been some sort of financial help to
people who are in mortgage crisis I
suppose much in the way that we had
those fuel payments
um during the winter months but instead
the The Daily Mail and a lot of the
other papers are reporting Jeremy Hunt's
plans he signed up a charter with some
of the major lenders so far HSBC at
Barclays have both signed up to this to
say that they will give people a minimum
of 12 months from the date of their
first default before they initiate um
repossession proceedings I think
currently it's around three months a
minimum of three months and then there's
other ideas such as letting people go
onto an interest only mortgage for six
months or let them extend the life of
their mortgage but all of that is
obviously just delaying or sort of
putting the the problems down the road
about my own mortgage my fix rate ran
out
um two months ago and it has jumped by
115 pound a month
um which you know it'll be fine I'll
cope but I mean it's enough to put a lot
of people's you know lights out if
they're working there very tight budget
and a lot of people are in a lot worse
situations than that I know so many
people who are saying that their
mortgage payments have jumped so much
they're going to have to maybe get rid
of their car they're going to have to
make other massive Savings in order to
deal with it and the last thing the
government wants is a repeat of that
crisis of 2008 when we've seen so many
people lost their homes as a result of
the financial crisis so clearly this is
all an attempt to try and make sure that
we don't have a repeat of what happened
there that's a huge amount of money
you're talking about Alison and we know
Anita that
2.4 million households are coming off
fixed-rate mortgages next year of course
next year is an important year isn't it
politically because it's going to be a
general election year as well I mean do
you think that the conservative
government are doing enough when you
hear the likes of Labor saying it's a
weak response the liberal Democrats
saying it's a sticking plaster for a
gushing wound what do you think
well I think this is all very much
politics because the reality of the
situation is the government's proposal
and agreement with the lenders goes
further than what labor suggested for
instance
um around the kind of grace period they
wanted six months the the government has
agreed with the lenders a 12-month grace
period
um but the fundamental issue here that
the government is seeking to tackle
alongside the bank of England is high
inflation and inflation makes absolutely
everybody poorer and it has devastating
effects particularly on the most poor
and so you know increasing interest
rates which is very painful is A bank's
way of being able to reduce people's
spending power in order to get inflation
under control so the government is not
going to be able to counter counter
balance so what what the interest rates
are supposed to do by giving people more
money because that will not tackle the
core issue which is inflation so I think
there's quite a lot of politics here in
labor of the liberal Democrats saying
the government isn't doing enough
because they they know that if the
government were to to sort of say well
actually we're going to make sure that
people have more financial help
um in the form of I don't know reduced
payments or payment to support that
would counterbalance what the interest
rate Rises are supposed to achieve
um and so fundamentally I think what the
government is hoping is that in helping
the very very small number of people who
will be really deeply affected by this
so in terms of those mortgage rate of
payers who you know are in danger of you
know forbearance effectively so needing
this drastic help you keep that safety
net very strong in agreement with
lenders but you do allow interest rates
to stay where they are in order to
tackle inflation is the approach that
they're taking which makes sense to me
yeah well let's continue the discussion
and look at how other newspapers are
covering it the ft weekends front page
as you would imagine has got this as
their main story and and just reading a
bit further into that article Allison
that they they quote Pantheon economics
that forecast today that house prices
are going to fall 10 percent Peak to
trough after previously anticipating an
eight percent fall adding that they
expect the downtown to be drawn out with
prices not reaching the floor until the
beginning of 2024 I mean it's very Grim
news isn't it potentially
and it is and I mean this is an obvious
um it's an obvious knock-on effect from
what is happening financially everywhere
else because as the interest rate people
just can't afford mortgages but it also
means that people are stuck in a a sort
of rental cycle where they're paying
very high rent to live somewhere which
means they don't have any savings and it
means they'll probably never get on the
property ladder in their lifetime
um and this is all again I mean whether
or not they delay and part of this
obviously the repossession that they're
not allowed to start
um forbidden proceedings until 12 months
but if you have a young family and
you're struggling it doesn't matter
whether you're gonna lose your house in
three months or 12 months you're going
to lose your home and that then pushes
up and pressure on the rental market as
well because there's just less homes and
more demand and the price of that goes
up so this has a massive knock-on effect
which will continue well after this
current crisis that we see ourselves in
into the years that come because as we
know from what happened in 2008 and 2009
and during that property bubble and all
of that buster took it took a decade for
that just this isn't going to be
something that's going to be resolved in
a year or two okay we're going to
continue the discussion in our 11
o'clock area on Sky News let's have a
look at some other uh front pages now
and Anita back to you on the front page
of the Daily Mirror they choose a
different story to go with the news
today that doctors are going to go for a
five-day strike five days in a row we
have to say next month to coincide we
believe we're the 70th anniversary of
the NHS and what do you make of their
coverage in this story
well yes as you say this is going to
have huge impact on the NHS and the
country at large um the mirror announces
that there's going to be this five-day
um strike from the 13th until the 18th
of July
um and that will obviously see thousands
of operations canceled this will be the
fourth strike um by Junior doctors in
England and
um you know the the fundamentals here of
the British Medical Association
um is asking for a 35 pay increase
um which the government says is
unaffordable
um and I the labor
um Health secretary West cheating agrees
um and the government is offered a five
percent paid bump to uh offer to two end
the disputes so it does it looks like
the two sides are very very far apart
um and once again you're going to have a
situation where so many operations are
canceled and the knock-on impact on NHS
waiting lists will be you know loud and
clear yeah and and more misery for
patients as you say who have been
waiting long enough anyway on the NHS
um let's bring you back here Alison and
tie this with the front page of the
times because it does go quite well in
terms of their lead story that being a
potential pay blow for millions of
public sector workers the Times
newspaper says that millions of public
sector workers face having their pay
Rises of six percent blocked by the
government amid mounting concerns that
they will fuel inflation of course we
know that that Junior doctors and nurses
are involved in that as well let me tell
us more
yeah I mean they're standard obviously
the government if they increase the the
pay which in terms of inflation most
people have have received what is an
effect of pay cut over the last five
years because inflation has increased
much quicker than especially those sort
of public sector wages have that people
it's going to fuel inflation just by
paying people a wage that they can
manage to survive on it's quite
short-sighted because if you look at
what the murderer said about the doctor
strike and then if you look at other
public services
um and other threats of strikes in
relation to that as well that costs so
much more than it would to try and
negotiate a decent pay pay raise for
those workers who are essential workers
these are the people we stood at doors
and clapped for you know during the the
covert pandemic if they are paying a
decent wage that they're able then to go
to work we don't have these knock-on
strikes I mean that's obviously a saving
to the government and also a saving the
people especially those who are on
Hospital witnessed I I live in a part of
the UK that has the highest win list in
the UK Northern Ireland Health Services
practically on its knees it just is no
longer a function and there's no longer
free healthcare at the point of need
because there is such a big backlog and
such long-witness and that is something
that you know in terms of the longer not
going to affect on people's Health we
know that the people don't receive
Health
um health care and proper Healthcare
when they need it at that time but that
knocks on the more serious symptoms and
more serious illnesses which just in the
long run end up costing more money to
trade are ultimately it means that
people lose their lives prematurely so I
do think that you know the government's
going to have to come a bit further but
also some of those public sector unions
are maybe going to have to move back a
little bit in order to meet the
government as well in order to resolve
this but just simply saying no we can't
give you our waves that you can live on
because it will increase inflation I
don't think that that is a good enough
answer yeah it needs if we read into the
article a bit more it says ministers are
weighing up the private recommendations
from the pay review bodies and two
senior government sources have told the
newspaper they are likely to take the
rare step of overruling some of those
recommend Nations I mean that's a bold
move from the government isn't it
particularly when they've already got a
fight in their hand with many public
sector workers
yes it is but I think we have to return
to the central issue which is inflation
now I'm not saying that the reason for
inflation is you know wage spiral like
that's not what I'm saying I'm saying
that actually we know the causes of
inflation were you know hugely Global
but the thing the government has to work
flat out to try to prevent is that
inflation becoming embedded deeply
embedded in the UK economy such that
everybody gets poorer in ways that is
you know can be potentially devastating
so the government is looking at doing
absolutely everything it can to Bear
down on some of the factors that can
increase inflation and so the
independent pay review bodies obviously
been an incredibly important part of the
negotiation and determining what kind of
recommendation makes sense taking into
account everything to do with the
economy but I think the government here
is the settings of managing some
expectations here there may need to be
some tough decisions taken and I don't
envy the government in this because they
absolutely want to retain and um you
know a motivate staff they they know
they have challenges to deliver at the
kind of Public Services that people want
but they also know they have to manage
and tame the tiger of inflation or the
pain could get much much much worse and
so this is going to be dancing on a head
of a pin and really really difficult and
tense negotiations to come in a year
where you know the economy is already
you know when it looked when it comes to
the issue of inflation you know core
inflation remaining stubbornly High
um that there are the positive signs
that you might hype to see at this
moment um you know halfway through the
year and in a word Anita because we're
running out of time do you believe or do
you have faith that Richardson can halve
inflation by the end of the year as he
has promised to do
um I think that it's on a knife edge
okay thank you we'll leave it there
we'll come straight back to you after
this short break coming up next we're
going to look at this store it's on the
front page of the I newspaper tomorrow
UK hit by exemptic shortages for weight
loss drugs we'll get more on that with
our columnists in just a few minutes
time see you shortly
[Music]
thank you
hello there welcome back a very good
evening to you you're watching the Press
preview with me tonight is the economist
Alison Morris and the former
conservative special advisor Anita
botang great to have you both with us
tonight thanks so much for staying with
us and let's have a look at some of the
other Pages which are on the well sorry
as I should say which are on the front
pages tomorrow and we're going to start
with the Telegraph and the telegraph
ladies actually has got a lot of Stories
on its front page tomorrow a very small
one in the kind of bottom left-hand
corner it looks like so kirstalma labor
leader has done an interview with the
day Telegraph Allison maybe he's trying
to win over their readers who knows says
he doesn't want to and he's going to try
to avoid increasing income tax if he
wins the election next year
yeah well I mean he's not gonna find his
core vote you know we're doing doing a
do an interview sir but at the same time
too we know that there's an action
coming next year already we're in full
election mode and the polls are shown at
despite being quite a week later of the
opposition that um circular Stormer is
on track and we're saying that to to uh
have a a very small possibly majority
but certainly to build a former a
government after the next election
that's what examine for the thing is you
know he was it was has been dealing with
a complete turmoil that's been happening
in the conservative party for the last
year and that has no stable eyes so he's
up against a much more stable prime
minister and when she say next so a lot
of that will be Financial because we
know that a lot of what's going to be
part of that election what's going to be
appealing to voters is dealing with the
financial crisis that's dealing with
inflation the cost of living
um the price of food and supermarkets
the price of fuel all of those sort of
things and so that is a I think he's now
gone for that sort of middle England
vote the fault that he lost I'm quite
sort of in the last general election
um but at the same time too a lot of
what I have seen from Pure starmer a lot
of what he has said a lot of those
policies none of them are really very
substantially awesome baby at the minute
um but we'll see how it goes but yeah
it's an interesting move if you can see
that already they're already in full
election mode even though we've got
quite a bit of a time to go yeah I need
to let's get your views of course as a
former conservative special advisor do
you think so kirst armor if he becomes
prime minister could uh maybe could
avoid increasing income tax the top
earners in this country what do you
think
uh no in a word and it's interesting
that um the the headline says labor
won't raise top rate of tax but actually
what the what the story then says is
kisama said he does not want to increase
the top rated tax I think that labor is
grappling with a conundrum um that is
going to continue to bedevil it in the
next sort of year and a half which is
how do they set out a program that feels
genuinely new and exciting and offers
Solutions around whether it's you know
public sector investment and all of that
without making some pretty bold
commitments around how they're going to
pay for all of these um Innovations and
we've seen labor in recent weeks talk
about how it's not going to spend 28
billion pounds every single year the
minute it gets into power on their green
transformation but instead they're going
to ramp up to this amount of money and I
think that again they've accepted the
cost of borrowing and going up and
that's going to be expensive so I think
that this Dynamic around them showing
more lag Beyond with tiny amounts of tax
raising that they've talked about right
now is going to be quite important I'm
going to jump in just because we're
running out of time and I really want to
get to the front page of the eye
newspaper Allison to you first UK hit by
azempik shortage this is the type 2
diabetes weight loss drug tell us more
very briefly
yeah and I think this is a lot of this
is fueled by celebrities people like
Elon Musk who said that they're using
the same thing you know there's a lot of
speculation and other
um very high profile celebrities have
been using this ambig to lose massive
amounts of weight and that obviously
filters down especially you know the
very sort of young men and women who are
maybe being influenced by that and so
it's created a shortage which means that
there's a shortage of the drug in terms
of what it's actually intended to do
what it was made for which was not as a
weight loss stroke but as a joke for um
type 2 diabetics okay hold that thought
plenty more from both of you uh from 11
o'clock onwards do you stay with us
thank you so much for joining us